THE PRESIDENT'S CHANCES WILL
DEPEND ON WHICH DEMOCRAT RUNS
AGAINST HIM.
WHO GETS THE NOMINATION?
SADLY FOR THE PRESIDENT, THE
PRESIDENT WILL ALMOST CERTAINLY
NOT BE BETO O'ROURKE.
HE'S FALLING AT ABOUT 2%.
THAT'S GOOD NEWS FOR AMERICA.
HE SPOKE FOR JUST ABOUT
10 MINUTES.
IT WAS AMAZING HOW MUCH LUNACY
HE MANAGED TO CRAM IN AND SUCH A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
HE BEGAN HIS SPEECH BY
DENOUNCING THE COUNTRY'S RACISM.
HE ANNOUNCED THAT AMERICA IS AN
EVIL NATION.
>> THIS IS A COUNTRY THAT HAS
BEEN DEFINED BY FOUNDATIONAL
SYSTEMIC RACISM SINCE THE VERY
FOUNDING OF THIS COUNTRY.
AUGUST 20TH OF 1619, THE FIRST
TIME THAT AN AFRICAN WAS BROUGHT
HERE AGAINST HIS WILL AND MADE
TO BRING THE WEALTH OF THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS IS THE REALITY OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, AND
SOONER OR LATER, IT WAS GOING TO
FIND US.
IT WASN'T A MATTER OF IF.
IT WAS A MATTER OF WHEN.
>> Tucker: WHAT A DISGUSTING
COUNTRY THIS IS, SAYS BETO.
BECAUSE THIS COUNTRY IS
FUNDAMENTALLY IMMORAL, AMERICANS
DON'T DESERVE THE SAME LIBERTIES
THAT THEY HAVE HAD SINCE THE
BEGINNING.
THEY WOULD USE THE REGISTRY TO
SEIZE THE FIREARMS OF
LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS.
>> THIS IS A COUNTRY THAT HAS
PRODUCED THE LEADERSHIP THAT
WILL ENSURE THAT WE NOT ONLY
HAVE UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS
AND READ FLAG LAWS AN END THE
SALE OF THOSE WEAPONS, BUT THAT
WE GO A NECESSARY STEP FORWARD,
AS DIFFICULT AS IT MAY BE.
A GUN REGISTRATION IN THIS
COUNTRY.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
AR-15s AND AK-47s WILL BE
BOUGHT BACK SO THEY ARE NOT ON
OUR STREETS, NOT IN OUR HOMES,
DO NOT TAKE THE LIVES OF OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS.
>> Tucker: OF THE MOST
NAUSEATING KIND OF TRUST FUND
POLITICS THAT BETO JUST
PERSONIFIES.
BUT REALLY, HE WAS ONLY HALF
DONE.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
INSANITY TO YOU, BUT BETO GOT
THAT OVER IN ABOUT 6 MINUTES.
HE WENT ON TO SAY THAT AMERICA
IS SO EVIL, SO RACIST, THAT IT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF THE
WORLD'S PROBLEMS.
ACCORDING TO BETO, AMERICAN
STOMACH AMERICA CAUSES MOST OF
THE WORLD'S PROBLEMS.
>> Beto: THE VIOLENCE, THE
PERSECUTION IS CAUSED NOT BY
GOD, NOR BY MOTHER NATURE, BUT
BY YOU AND ME.
>> Tucker: DID TRUST FUNDS
MAKE YOU DECADENT AND STUPID?
BETO O'ROURKE EXISTENCE KIND OF
ANSWERS THAT QUESTION, DOESN'T
IT?
WHAT IS THE PRICE WE NEED TO PAY
FOR BEING THE SINFUL COUNTRY
THAT WE ARE?
BETO SAYS THAT WE MUST GIVE
AMNESTY.
>> Beto: WE ARE GOING TO
LEGALIZE.
THEY WILL NEVER AGAIN FEAR